- We are about to fight now.
- Wanna go?
'Cause we can go right now, dog.
- Don't hold me back, dog!
Don't hold me back!
- Fight by God!
(woman growling)
(both screaming)
(bell dinging)
(theme song playing)
(Key and Peele theme playing)
- I don't care.
- (slurring) situations--
- No but I don't care.
- And I'm trying to help
people out over here.
- No, okay.
You know what, Jacquelyn?
- No, I don't know, what?
- You need to think
about yourself sometimes
before you start insinuating yourself
in other people business.
- Well, you know what Denise?
I'm gonna insinuate my stuff
whenever and wherever I please
cuz it's a free country, bitch.
(crowd gasping)
- Uh-uh.
- Uh-huh.
- Uh-uh. Okay.
You know what?
- Oh, we doing this?
Okay, so we gonna do here babe.
- Yeah we are about to fight now.
- Bring it on in then, bitch.
Let's go.
- I ain't even playing,
'cause you know what?
- I wish you would.
- Step to me then.
- I wish--
- Go ahead.
- I wish you would.
- Step to me.
- Step up.
- No, I would love for you to step to me.
I really would.
- But you just talking.
- I don't even care no more.
And you talking now and
that's all you're doing.
- Call me a bitch again.
- Oh yeah?
See what happens.
- Your wish is granted.
- See what happens.
- Bitch, I would like to see what happens.
I would love to see what happens.
- Oh, you do?
- Oh, absolutely.
So why don't you come
and bring it then, bitch.
(crowd exclaiming)
- See. No.
You are riding my last nerve
and I ain't even playing no more.
I am not even playing no more.
- Oh, it's on?
Then let's do something, okay?
You want to go (underwear stretching)
(crowd yelling)
do something, bitch?
Uh-uh.
There we go.
Let's do something.
- Uh-uh.
- Uh-
huh.
- Uh-uh.
It's uh-huh.
- Let's do something, bitch!
(crowd gasping)
- What?
(zipper unzipping)
(intense drumming music)
[Little Girls] We told you
not to mess with us, bitch!
- Ya'll just saw that bitch
turn into two little girls, right?
(air whooshing)
(Key and Peele theme playing)
- Just gonna sit down
and relax a little bit.
- Hey, watch where the (beep) you go.
- Oh my gosh.
I'm so sorry.
- Oh.
(baby cooing)
I ain't see you had a baby there man.
I'm sorry.
I ain't trying to fight
nobody with a baby.
- Yeah. Hell yeah, you won't.
(man clearing throat)
(baby cooing)
- Lucky mother(beep).
- Well, you're lucky
I'm carrying this baby.
Something like that.
- Look, man.
You need to move on.
All right? I already told you.
I'm not gonna fight you.
- That's what I thought punk.
Wanna go?
Cause we can go right now, dog.
What's going on, brother?
- Man, what the hell are you doing, man?
- What, what?
What, what?
Trying to bob, I can bob and weave it.
- What?
- You bitch ass, punk ass, mother(beep).
Let's go.
Come on man.
Come on. No, don't look at your boys.
Look at me, man.
Don't look at your boy.
(slapping)
Ow!
Oh, okay. You think you hard.
All right but you know what?
I'm gonna show you what
time it is right now.
Okay?
Slap me.
Right?
How about this?
Huh? Now what's gonna do, huh?
Now what's gonna do?
You ready?
Cuz they can't do it right now.
Cuz I can take you out man.
(man painfully groaning)
- Okay.
Oh, it's on now.
That's, yep.
You dead.
Excuse me, I need this.
Yep.
(speaking Spanish)
(intense drumming music)
- What the?
- What now man?
What now?
Let's go.
- You know what?
It not even worth it, man.
- Ah! (laughs)
That's what I thought!
So keep walking.
(baby puking)
- Oh okay. That's vomit.
That is vomit.
(babies crying)
Oh dear.
(air whooshing)
(Key and Peele theme playing)
- But babe, moving out?
Please, this is the worst possible time.
Please don't do this.
Babe?
(sighing)
- Garbage.
- Huh?
- Can I take your garbage?
- Yeah, sure.
(janitor chuckling )
You know, I find the
more garbage in the can,
the better it feels to dump it all out.
(trash rustling)
I suppose that's why we let it get so full
in the first place.
So we can start over.
(snapping)
(light twinkling)
- Here to fix the copier.
- Yes. Sure, sure.
Hey, how did you--
- Sometimes things ain't really broken.
It's the way we treat 'em
that needs to be fixed.
(electricity buzzing)
(copier printing)
(repairman whistling)
(bird chirping)
(repairman chuckling)
- Who the hell are you guys?
- [Mystery Men] The important question is,
who are you, Steve?
(dramatic music playing)
- Well, if it isn't Mr. Stand there.
- Carl.
(dramatic music playing)
- You need to find your
own troubled white boy.
(dramatic music playing)
- I was here first.
- Copy cat!
(Carl coughing)
- Sweep this.
(electricity buzzes)
(Janitor grunting)
(Carl laughing)
(air whooshing)
(Carl grunting)
(Janitor laughing)
(electricity crackling)
(paper flapping in air)
(paper whooshing)
(air whooshing)
(Carl screaming angrily)
- Trust the field. (whistling)
(bird cawing)
(dramatic music)
- [Both Men] There can be only one
magical
negro!
(dramatic music playing)
(electricity crackling)
(electricity zapping)
(air whooshes)
(both screaming)
(explosion erupting)
(car horns beeping)
(glass shattering)
(papers fluttering)
(electricity crackling)
- Good Lord.
Are you all right?
Well, I guess sometimes
things have to come apart
before we can put 'em back together again.
- Oh!
You're a magical negro too?
- Who you calling negro, bitch?
(air whooshing)
(Key and Peele theme playing)
- Well.
All right friends.
The first fight of the
evening will feature
one of my slaves versus one of
the slaves of my distinguished guest.
Mr. Jacob Dixon.
- You know Robert, I
hope you're as gracious
a loser as you are a host.
(men laughing)
- All right, enough talk.
(Robert's fingers snapping)
Now.
Fight you devils.
Fight to the death.
(Mr. Dixon laughs)
(rhythmic drumming playing)
- Hey. Hey.
Question?
How do we get out of this thing alive?
- It's really simple.
Just let me pretend to kill you.
- Hmm.
- Maybe it just makes more
sense if I pretend to kill you.
- Yeah.
- I wanna make it believable.
So.
- That's what I was going for too.
- What the blazes is going on over there
and that endless clench?
Tear him apart.
- Okay.
(men yelling)
- Just, die from this.
- From this?
You know what?
Something doesn't feel right.
So if I can just,
Go with me here.
(men yelling)
- That was it. That was it.
This feels much more real, so.
- What, why?
- Sorry, what do you mean, why?
- Fight by God!
(rhythmic drumming playing)
- I'm getting frustrated now.
- Damn it!
Kill!
(men grunting)
- Nope, not a thing.
Not a thing.
- I need to just get (grunting)
I'm gonna get him, I got em.
Just let get you though.
- No, let me get you.
It was my idea so can I do it?
Let me get you though.
- Let me get you.
- Can you just let me
get you for a second?
- I'll let you--
- Stop fighting like
sissies and kill each other!
- Oh, right.
(men groaning)
- So let's just check this out.
- All right.
- We'll back up and you
run at me real fast.
Just do a bunch of spins
and kicks and flourishes.
I'll just knock you out one punch
and then you're dead.
- No, wait, wait, what?
I'm sorry, so you can look cool?
No, thank you.
- If someone doesn't die soon,
I will kill you both.
- Thank you.
(men yelling)
That's my boy.
- You're not getting stronger
from my punches.
- I am though!
- Come here.
Now listen, let's be fair.
Okay? We both slam into each other
and we both die.
Fair?
- That's fair.
(men grunting)
- One!
- This'll be good.
- Two.
[Both Men] Three!
(men yelling)
- What?
- Oh, you son of a bitch.
- You were never gonna fall.
- You didn't even try to fall.
It was the fakest thing I've ever--
(slapping)
- Don't.
(men arguing)
- [Robert] What in
tarnation are you two doing?
- Ope. You hit my balls.
- Hey everybody.
War's over.
Slavery is abolished.
Sorry.
- We'll call it a draw.
- Done.
- Good for you though, huh?
- Thank you?
- Let's go.
- Well, wait before you
no, no, no no, no, no.
- Hold up. Hold up.
- If I may, who do you think
would've won the fight?
- Yeah. Between the two of us.
(air whooshing)
(Key and Peele theme playing)
- I said it right there.
I was like you a woman.
I'm a man.
There's a difference between--
Oh! What?
They bumping this (beep) up in here?
Here it is. It's going off.
Yo!
Hey!
(man claps)
Which one of y'all mother(beep)
(heavy rap music playing)
bumped me?
- I did.
(beep) you going to do about it?
- What is that?
(heavy rap music playing)
- I'll tell you what I'm gonna about it!
- We don't wanna do this today.
- Oh yeah.
Yeah what? You lucky
my friends holding me!
You lucky!
Cause I'll tear your head off.
Don't hold me back, dog!
Don't hold me back!
- Oh, okay. Then go for it.
(heavy rap music playing)
- See, I know though,
if I were to lunge at you right now,
my friend right here,
he'd catch me at the last possible second.
- No, no, no I won't.
(heavy rap music playing)
- But my friend does have the cognizance
to tell me I don't need to be going up
and committing capital
murder up in a club tonight.
- Oh no, just knock him unconscious, dog.
(imitates punching sound)
Don't have to kill anybody.
No need for that, that's excessive.
Tear him up!
(heavy rap music playing)
- I will.
But let me finish my sentence.
(heavy rap music playing)
Oh, snap!
You know what?
You lucky my boy's using
his telekinetic powers
to hold me back right now.
- No, I'm not.
- Well maybe...
it's the type of telekinesis
that's a mutant power
that you didn't realize you had
until the moment it starts.
- Oh! Oh, I got it.
I see. I see.
So you want me to hold you (beep)?
(men grunting and yelling)
- I'm a dragon.
(men growling)
Oh yeah. I wanna rip this, I'm a lion.
I'm a tiger over here.
I'm a bear.
Oh my.
I go crazy on you.
- Oh, I can't believe this.
He's like a tornado up in here!
- Don't hold me back.
- I can't even believe
I can hold him back.
- Do it, man.
- I can't believe I'm this strong.
- Let me go!
- Look at this,
I'm one arming it.
I can't believe I'm this strong.
- Let me go!
- Look at this man,
I'm holding him with one finger.
He's like a little baby.
He can't get past me.
He like a little-- Ow!
What?
- I'm a little baby?
- I'm holding you back, man.
- (beep) stupid, man.
- I know, I got carried away.
I apologize.
- What you mean you got carried away?
- You told me, hold you back.
I was holding you back.
What do you want me to do?
- In a fight situation,
no means no and yes means yes.
- How would I have known that?
- Oh, what? Come on man.
Ow. Come on. That hurt.
(man yells)
And you holding me back now.
Thank you very much for that.
(man yelling)
Okay. Well just at least change it up.
Oh! Okay. Now you listen.
(air whooshing)
(Key and Peele theme playing)
(organ music playing)
(woman sighing)
- Happy Sunday, Esther.
- Happy Sunday, Georgina.
How was your week?
- Ooh, the Lord is with me,
but the devil,
he got his hands on my grand niece Grace.
- Oh no.
- They're smoking the reefer
and doing the Hanky Panky with boys.
- Oh Georgina.
- Oh Esther, you know
that I love all things
that are good and holy.
But if he doesn't let go
of my grand niece Grace,
I'm going to cut the devil's dick off
and shove it in his ass.
With my prayers.
- I know you will, Georgina.
I know you will.
- How was your week girl?
- Oh, you know me.
I'm blessed and thankful for every day.
- All right.
- But you know my grandson Jason
got his self wrapped up in
the leathery claws of Satan.
- (gasping) Not Jason.
- He got his self arrested
for the spray painting
and the vandalisms.
- Oh Lord.
- And I tell you, I never
raised my hand in anger
but if he don't let Jason go,
I'm going punch that
nigga Satan in the nuts
so hard and wipe the dick licking smirk
off his horned ass face.
With my prayers.
- Amen. I know you will, Esther.
I know you will, but Esther
I gotta tell you something else now.
- Let it out.
- You know Esther, that
I have found serenity
in the glory of Heaven.
- Yes!
- But my daughter's
husband Bernard has got
himself wedged between the
cleft hooves of Lucifer himself.
She opened up his laptop computer
and found the pornography of women.
- Not the pornography of women.
- Absolutely the pornography of women.
- Not on the laptop computer.
- The laptop computer with
the pornography of women.
I am a pacifist under God's request.
But if he don't let go of Bernard,
I'm going to sneak up on
that bitch ass Lucifer
right in the midst of his sleep time.
And then I'm gonna sit on
that motherfucker's head
and I'm gonna spread my booty
cheeks on that pigs face.
And I'm on just pucker up my stank hole
and just toops, toops, toops,
scoops, boodoop, scoop, scoop, scadoops.
Until that nigga got a
brown dot on his nose
that I can use for target practice.
(imitating gunfire)
- Oh! Shoot that nigga in the shit dot!
- With my prayers.
- With your prayers of course, of course.
Oh Georgina, Georgina, Georgina.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, I got nothing but
faith in God in Heaven above
but I tell you my son's wife, Crystal,
she got self wrapped up in the fiery wings
of Mephistopheles herself.
- Here we go.
- You know, she got caught using profanity
with her own children.
- What?
- At the dinner table.
- Oh Lord, child!
- Georgina Darlene Martin!
Oh!
I have nothing but love for
every creature on this planet
but if he don't let my darling Crystal go,
I'm gonna flirt with the devil.
- Oh, oh!
- Show him a little bit of shoulder.
How you doing?
He gonna start looking away.
I'm gonna start twerking.
Start twerking.
He gonna be like, Ooh,
he gonna be drawn in.
Seduce that little motherfucker.
Give him one of these.
Hi!
Bat my eyelashes at him.
Then when he least expects
it and I got his trust,
that's when I'm going ride that nigga.
I'm gonna give him a night of his life.
A night he ain't never going to forget.
- Go get him.
- I'm gonna give him this way.
I'm gonna give him that way.
And then right when he about the climax,
that's when I'm going clench up my pussy
on that motherfucker's red dick
and I'm going snap that nigga cock off
with a divine kegel.
- Well, you gotta snap
that nigga dick off!
Snap it off!
- With my prayers.
- With your prayers.
Of course, with the prayers.
But that's right girl!
- Yes!
- You go get him, Esther!
- Fuck Satan!
- Fuck him!
- Fuck. Him. In. The--
(suspenseful music)
(guttural groaning)
(air whooshing)
- What's happening, Georgina?
- Georgina isn't here anymore.
(evil laughing)
- It is I,
Satan.
(Esther yells)
(Satan grunting)
- Nah, Esther I'm in here now.
I'm kicking this nigga's ass!
(Satan grunting and groaning)
- [Satan] Somebody help me,
I've gotta get out of this bitch.
(Georgina screaming)
- Get him Georgina!
Get him!
- I stuck a safety pin
in this nigga's urethra.
(Satan screaming in pain)
- [Satan] Fuck!
That hurts!
- Now I got his dick in my hands,
like an old rag, I'm ringing it out!
I'm ringing it out!
- Oh, give me some of that.
I want a piece of him.
Yeah, tag me in!
(air whooshing)
(Esther yelling)
(Satan groaning)
- [Satan] Who is this crazy bitch, now?
- (yells) It's me motherfucker,
your worst nightmare bitch!
(Esther maniacally laughing)
- Suplex that motherfucker!
- I'm on top of you,
I'm gonna grab him.
- [Satan] (yells) What's going on?
This feels good.
Why would you do this to me?
- Oh, you'll see in a second motherfucker!
- [Satan] I'm waiting but here I come!
Here I come!
(Esther yelling)
(cracking)
- Oh!
- Oh, I got him good.
- [Satan] I'll do anything you say.
I'll do anything you say.
- Too late now!
Too late now, Satan!
(shushing)
We should probably go.
- Oh yeah let's go, let's go.
- We don't wanna disturb the service.
- Oh, I got hold of him.
We gonna go medieval on his ass.
(air whooshing)
- [Satan] Uh-oh. No!
No!
I can't take it!
I can't--
- Get over here mister!
- [Satan] Please. Please.
Get these crazy bitches off of me!
(Satan crying)
Jesus Christ is my
personal Lord and savior.
I swear.
- [Esther] You're too late for that now!
(Satan crying)
(Key and Peele theme playing)